Hey, everyone.
Welcome to Abstract
Video Tutorials.
Today, we're going to be
looking at how you can
automatically send emails
from a spreadsheet.
All right.
Now, the tutorial actually
resides in our dev site at
developers.googl
e.com/appsscript.
If you go to this intermediate
tutorial section here and go
to Send Emails With a
Spreadsheet, here's a tutorial.
Now, as it says here,
it takes 10 minutes.
But it's actually much
quicker than that.
So we'll run through that
really quickly.
I'm going to get rid of
these extra tabs.
Now, this is a container-bound
script.
So it lives within
a spreadsheet.
So first, we need to go to
Drive and create a new
spreadsheet.
We'll give it an appropriate
name.
All right.
In order to paste this code
snippet in, we need to access
the script editor, which
you get to from
Tools, Script Editor.
Let's grab this code here.
And once the script editor
opens, this will paste the
code here from the tutorial and
give this a name as well--
if I can spell correctly,
but it doesn't matter.
Save it.
Now, the tutorial says that the
set up for the script is
you need some fake data in your
spreadsheet so that you
can test it out.
So let's say, for this example,
we're planning a
party and we get together in a
room and in a spreadsheet, we
decide who does what.
In this email, we have an
Email Address column.
And then we also have
a Message column.
Now, because this is a test,
we're going to be sending all
the emails to a test account.
But as you can imagine,
this could go to
various different people.
So let's just send
two emails here.
And the message will be "Pick
up the balloons." And then
this one will be "Invite
guests." So if this works
properly, this person will
get an email saying, as a
reminder, to pick up the
balloons, and this person will
get an invite guests reminder.
We'll go here into our
script editor and run
the send emails function.
Now, you need to authorize it to
use Gmail to send messages
on your behalf.
So I'll go ahead and
do that here.
I'll go ahead and
run it again.
Now, it ran.
When we go to our Gmail, we'll
see the two messages from the
current time.
And the first message is "Invite
guests." And the next
one is "Pick up the balloons,"
as we expected.
And now, an extension to the
script that's noted in the
tutorial-- let's go ahead
and delete the old data.
Actually, we didn't
need to do that.
Grab this other code right here
and just copy paste over
the existing code.
Now, this will give you a
Send Emails To method.
When you run it, you'll see that
in the spreadsheet, it
marks a third column
with EMAIL_SENT.
This is so that if you wanted
to resume running the script
at a later date, it's not
going to send these same
emails to these same
people again.
It'll mark it as done.
And if you go back to your
inbox, you'll see two more
emails arrive.
As just a proof, if you click
it again, because it already
has that EMAIL_SENT column,
you're not going to see any
more emails come through.
That, in a nutshell, is it.
Now, let me just briefly walk
you through the code here.
All it does is it gets the
active spreadsheet.
It says that the start
row is 2 because you
have a header row.
And it gets the data from that
sheet as a 2D array.
And within this, it goes through
that array and assigns
each of the columns to a
variable here-- email address
variable and the message
variable.
And this is the advanced
example.
So it also has the EMAIL_SENT
variable to
mark that third column.
And basically, all it does is
MailApp.sendEmail, specifying
the address, the subject of
the message, and then the
actual message itself, and
then sends that through.
And here, what you see is it's
marking the third column with
the value in emailSent which,
if you scroll up, is
EMAIL_SENT.
And that's it-- as
simple as that.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Tune back for some of
our other tutorials.
My name, again, is
Kalyan Reddy.
Goodbye.